cependant le confinement il ya plein de
choses sur les réseaux sociaux qu en
profite pour dire ce qu'ils pensent
qu'en sortir pour faire kiffer et on va
jouer au punch line du jour d'accord on
line gagne quoi pour les pommes seul but
vous allez c'est parti d'une gueule
punchline du jour c'est bon merci alors
tout cas lâché la punchline on ne
confond pas une f1 avec une voiture de
karting
nabila qui parlait de king lauch copé
karim benzema à propos d'olivier giroud
ou passe partout sur fabien lecoeuvre
[Rires]
c'est karim benzema karim benzema alors
je tiens à dire je suis potec les doutes
voilà je dirais que très potes voilà
avec olivier giroud et je suis content
aussi et karim benzema
j'aime beaucoup et benzema sur giroud
dans un dans un un style hier soir avec
moi mais déni il a dit ça et forcément
je vous dis ça a été repris par tous et
les mecs qu'ils arrivent et ils ont
commandé là ils veulent faire bien il
doit regarder d'abord ce qu'avait dit
karim et après on va voir ce qu'il a
duré du karim s'apprend pas de 1 karim
benzema à la je vois le truc c'est carré
à son oeuvre également des génies de
l'orthographe un merci des chiens
merci les gars auraient dû vous êtes
géniaux mais c'est vrai que karim eux et
ils ont cru que c'était karin benzema
carrie de pas quitté la salle en ligne
et à laisser partir regardez ce qu'a dit
karim est ce que tu penses que giroud
est ce qu il a le potentiel près
titulaire à ta place en équipe de france
en gros faut se battre je vais répondre
à toi et à tous ceux qui aiment bien ça
va être vite fait ça va être vite fait
les mecs on ne confond pas la f1 on ne
confond pas la f1 et le karting et je
suis gentil
voilà maintenant next je parle même plus
c'est tranquille quatre mois je sais de
chlef s'est soudain voilà alors karim
benzema cadix a su réagir on est vu que
ça fait pas mal de bruit de karim il a
voulu revenir dessus aujourd'hui et
gardez ce qu'il a dit olivier giroud
déjà où j'ai dit la vérité tout
simplement on n'a pas retenu le fait où
je parler de lui ce qu'il apportait en
équipe de france on a retenu juste quand
j'ai dit que j'étais la f1 et lui car
c'est ce que je pense et c'est la vérité
et c'est comme ça puisque maintenant on
regarde si tu me demandes avec air 9h09
c'est la f1 et moi je suis de karting
c'est comme ça bref on va passer à autre
chose que nous avons alors r9 est pas un
menteur canaux ronaldo mais voilà et
c'est vrai que karim benzema
moi je vous dis c'est un c'est un mec
voilà que je connais bien qui rira un
amour de gars franchement c'est un amour
de galilée fronde mois ci c'est dommage
j'en ai marre des mecs qui sont co dit
c'est vrai mais non et tout le monde est
bien et tout le monde est bout et tout
donner car mine de rien il dit les
choses
moi franchement je le kiffe ce gars 1
gilles questembert ces études est
entièrement d'accord dans le monde
aseptisé qui disent qu'ils pensent qu'il
fait des déclarations et en plus sur le
fond moi je vais vous dire honnêtement
je sais que vous êtes ami avec et
d'autre mais moi je vais vous dire il a
raison
karim benzema pour moi sur le plan du
talent il a un olivier giroud dans
chaque pied au qui peut le dire oui
enfin oui giro c'est le karting alors
olivier aucun super pouvoir
ai-je paul girot la coupe du monde grâce
à lui aussi au leader je sais que hérité
fans il va dire mais moi en tout cas le
personnage de karim voyage l'audi et
faire j'espère qu'il me regarde ailleurs
j'ai perdu ton demeure tu peux l'envoyer
voilà je le kiffe karim parce que ces
îles et il est sympathique et c'est pas
un méchant karim un giuly c'est pas du
tout en mission dans les débats
sympathie qu'il a mais jusqu'au oui mais
oui mais est-ce que tu le connais est-ce
que tu le connais que franchement je
juge sur ce qui dit manon moi aussi non
mais dominés 2 minutes direction juste
sur ce que je dis
ben alors moi aussi alors aussi moi je
suis une espèce de karim benzema de la
télé l'an puisque swing de rien je dis
la vérité je dis ce que je pense
alors après il ya des gens comme toi que
vous donnez moi je discute pas c'est pas
vraiment le débat le dans le débat c'est
ce qu'il dit ça explique pourquoi il
n'est plus sélectionné en équipe de
france c'est quelqu'un qui a une bonne
mentalité
ce qui existe mais il sent tard en
parlant de lui même pour ça complètement
déplacé mais moi je rencontrais on
effraie gironde a gagné la coupe et les
avec wade
entre la grâce à part en chemin
franchement je pense que c'est le crème
aux esprits geste les gens non mais je
finis sur internet
j'espérais qu'on avait fini avec ce
genre d'histoire ces petites
déclarations
c'est ce comportement égoïste cc 32
salles ben tu vois je te dise est resté
typiquement le genre de mec qui va faire
après je t'adore un tu le sais qui va
faire des commentaires sur twitter sur
un stade qui peut les faire même sur moi
quand je fais une vanne sur j sur
beaugrand ou sur quelqu'un d'autre
karim il dit moi ça me donne et son
front karim en plus il se fait chier à
faire un instant il un qui tu crois que
tu arrives il a besoin de ça sans
rigoler il ya des abrutis qui lui tombe
dessus ça ça me rend ouf
donc il doit parler on n'a pas le droit
de commenter ce sont six mais bon on
peut dire ce qu'on pense aussi voilà tu
as tu as dit à béton elle est vraiment
une question sur la déclaration de la
trouve lamentable qui se comportent très
mal c'est insupportable sa voix son rire
et je vous l'aurais cru quand il jouait
en équipe de france est passé par des
périodes très difficiles on l'a vu faire
dix matches et marqué un but personne ne
le traitez de dos de 4 ans va pas
remettre et dans le foot les mecs on
n'est pas des démissions guérilla et
raymond y rester parce que oui moi je
comprends que j'ai moi de contredire la
docteure oui à dire et ses passages
croire que veut dire eric naulleau mais
en même temps c'est c'est comme du
chambrage et c'est ce que fait benzema
avec avec moi mais là bien sûr pas c'est
juste te dire la ville et pas en équipe
de france et régionaux a donné la coupe
du monde c'est plus du 100 brasse et il
le dit comme ça parce que lui les
parents plaçant ici la ville vraiment
une mauvaise mentalité comme tu dirais
qu'ils seraient pas titulaires autant
temps réel avec autant d'entraîneurs qui
l'on essaie titulaire et pacha il se
permet avec l'équipe de france je
parlais pas effleuré au chômage parce
que je trouve dommage c'est que il ya eu
plein de choses de 10 il a vanté les
mérites de giroud sur l'équipe de france
il arrivera t il à dit oui voilà pour
juin et au delà de ça c'est la montée la
police a cessé la liaison c'est trop aux
clients sur le lin cela dit hier il a
dit qu'il a dit sur le un stade hier ils
ramènent ronaldo quand même g n et
renard exactement sont bâtis
neyreneuf est prévu ce qui l'a déjà fait
il a dix mois - ernotte c'est là c'est
la f1 moi je suis karting avant la mini
la fonte et syrie la fonte et une ati
que gillou est très intéressant pour m
ap et pour crise maladroit qui n'étaient
à l'équipe de france dans son rôle sauf
que ça n'a pas été repris et ça c'est
encore des mecs ça c'est encore des mecs
qui veulent [ __ ] la merde mais
arriveront sur l'apport des mecs qui
veulent [ __ ] la merde qui prennent
qu'une phrase missiles sol-air 12,6
après souper
c'est encore des mecs moi je pense que
c'est encore des mecs qui foutent la
merde qui prend une phrase ici une
phrase par là il à dire ni l'horaire
qu'il était utile en équipe de france
believe et giroud ya pas un mec caf un
titre sur karim benzema a dit olivier
giroud est utile en équipe de france
elle des mecs qui ont fait des titres
car et karim benzema
cela dit géniale invention mais c'est
une merde moi envolée que je me dis moi
moi j'aurais pu la faire cette vanne
j'aurais très bien pu dire je te le dis
que j'aurais pu faire cette demande
vraiment où j'aurais pas pu la faire
cette vanne mois mais bien sûr c'est une
vanne de vestiaire celui qui a joué ou
fourni c'est très bien et je le répète
c'est brad mois on a vécu quand tu vois
le journal l'équipe qui reprend ça et
qui reprend mais pas le câble et ronaldo
dans le live un stade ça c'est pas
professionnel des métiers des mauvais
choix je veux dire regardez moi je vais
vous dire pareil on voit là nagui
foucault drucker c'est la f1 moi je suis
karting voilà après tu mets et les
autres là bas les autres s'ils sont en
karting je suis en f1
la mer voilà c'est tout je le dis voilà
voilà je le dis voilà c'est tour là
allez les mecs
tiens qui a dit qu'il ferme sa gueule
il y en a marre des gens comme lui
christophe beaugrand à matthieu
delormeau à peu près toutes les
personnes qui ont croisé un jour gilbert
daniel cohn bendit au professeur à
l'école l'année alors est lui aussi est
lui aussi au sirop vous allez me donner
votre avis sur les rugbyphiles à 1800
rigoler ça fait cent ans qui
l'approchent qu'un pavé vient chercher
tout
[Rires]
rien dit oui mais non c'était pas les
bonnes
voilà j'en sais rien mais le raout mais
que raoult dit qu'il n'y a que lui
c'est comme quand va où c'est le vase
l'ailier il va à la télévision il dit
mais arrêtez de me casser les pieds avec
le corps d'avis rue ce n'est qu'une
grippe se derrien c'est pas parce qu'il
ya trois chinois qui éternue que tout le
monde de loi se met trop bien on la
comprend le donation play tombée de la
nuit
voilà on est de faire des trucs qui
ferme sa gueule et qu'ils soient
médecins
mais qu'il arrête partout de dire je
suis jeune j'ai dit allez conjoint
d'albi non mais enfin cette journée sont
le résultat c'est ça mais on est
d'accord ce genre de mec est bon
j'espère les chéris vous kiffez
démission parce que la jonquille total
lundi assuré que ça ça hein ça bouscule
aujourd'hui revient alors sur lacaune
bendit est ce que vous êtes d'accord sur
ce qu'il dit là qu'ils soient adultes ou
alors allez faisons fi non mais cohn
bendit effectivement fois qu'il ferme sa
gueule vraiment lui alors là pour le
coup en suisse estime des pétitions pour
soutenir les pédophiles en format c'est
tout à fait ce que je déteste dénonce
jamais donc voilà donc non il faut
qu'ils je vois pas l'intérêt en fait de
cracher de jeter la pierre
un type qui essaye de sauver des vies je
ne comprends pas le concept en fait ça
m'échappe
comme le dit il paye pas sa vie depuis
25 ans 30 ans à la télévision et une
qualification en dix ans il passe son
temps lui la télé idée n'importe quoi
ouais hallucinant on dirait on dirait
une crise de jalousie d'un gamin
notoriété du professeur raoul
on dirait une hystérique complètement
ridicule lui pour lutter contre
coronavirus le mec qui fait rien en fait
qu'il sert à rien qu'ils emmerdent tout
le monde et j'espère mais en plus de
juger les autres c'est vraiment ridicule
mais ça fait des années avec moi donner
ton avis là-dessus qui ferme sa gueule
c'est pas un élément de débat ça veut
rien dire
on a besoin de cette période où tout le
monde est paniqué on m'avait grands
espoirs sur la floride c'est d'avoir un
débat scientifique poser avec des vraies
réponses
il arrive pour dire qu'il ferme sa
gueule il aurait mieux fait de rester
chez lui voilà d'ailleurs pas d'accord
majid bâ vas-y vas-y a pas d'accord
parce que c'est un plateau télé où les
débats sont exacerbées qotbi on lui
demande son avis il est face à un
débatteur ouais c'est ça que c'est un
avis moi je suis de ceux qui croient
guère en avion
le professeur mais laissez moi finir je
suis de ceux qui considérait ces
constructions out c'est un héros mais il
sait se défendre il a plein de partisans
dont moi cohn-bendit a le droit de se
prononcer a le droit de dire ce qu'ils
pensent a le droit de dire qu'il en a
marre ils se prononcent pas
on décrète caché sa joie c'est univoque
1 c'est donc ça donne vraiment vraiment
le débat non moi je moi je suis d'accord
écrit je voudrais bien qu'ils aient le
débat y'a pas de soucis il n'y a pas de
débat
tu peux faire un débat sans insulter le
même surtout quand le mec il est même
pas un pan plateau tulle insulte à
distance jeudi qu'il ferme sa gueule
pourquoi elle fermerait sa gueule moi je
rejoins des camarades et ergil aussi qui
a dit que le professeur a quitté cannes
cannes bien on tape sur un mec qui a
inventé un truc on tape sur un mec
quelques premiers quand tu tapes car
c'est un scientifique cohn bendit il a
fait quoi parler calmement 68 écologie
les verts après il était faire de la
politique en france
hier il est on sait pas où elle en est
on sait pas ce qu'il fait les sophie
elle a mis le point tu avais fait dans
le passé a mais un chien l'a jamais été
jugés pour ça moi j'ai envie de dire
aussi à cohn bendit aussi mais là on est
sûr fait ne souffre un peu t3
extrêmement contre-productif
allez tout le monde a donné son avis
là-dessus aller bah non il y aurait une
troisième truc non valeur voulez vous
envoler le troisième mode chaîne yoopa
ah oui mais dit il est bien allé voilà
les attentions qu'il a dit qui a dit
avec la fnac fermé
laetitia l'idée ne pourra pas s'acheter
une douzième maison à saint barth bruno
masure dans un tweet
jacques legros audi au jt de 13h ou
david hallyday sur un stade avec l'esa
jure sur wii no ma mesure
voilà qui encore
à qui a encore fait parler lui lui son
gracieux géniteur sur twitter il arrête
pas de défoncer tout le monde à moi
aussi ma ds et qui est d'accord avec lui
qui trouve c'est une bonne vanne mois
pompeux 3g de 16 ans ne s'est même pas
de l'humour il est pas drôle il est
aigri and roll franchement ils emmerdent
tout le monde vous disiez que cohn
bendit se taisent bac majeur sans sa
gueule ils sont salubrité publique voilà
[Rires]
voilà
très bien